estas imágenes han dado la vuelta al
mundo el 9 de julio tras meses de
protestas por la peor crisis económica
desde la independencia de sri lanka los
manifestantes tomaron la residencia del
presidente gota Bahía raya y lograron lo
que están pidiendo en la calle desde
marzo que anunciará su división
este Debería ser el día más feliz de
nuestra vida porque el presidente nos
robó robó a nuestro país no es cuánta
gente está caminando afuera todavía no
hemos ganado no podemos recuperar su
dinero pero somos las personas más
felices creo que hablo en nombre de todo
el mundo en este país
los manifestantes exigieron a rayapaqsa
que asumiera la responsabilidad por la
escasez de medicamentos alimentos
electricidad y combustible que puso de
rodillas a la otra era rica economía
surasiática desde finales del año pasado
y provocó la miseria de los ciudadanos
según el programa mundial de alimentos
casi 5 millones de personas lo que
corresponde al 22% de la población
Necesitan ayuda alimentaria
solo podemos comprar unos 250 gramos de
pescado y a veces es solo un pescado
[Música]
tenemos que cortarlo en muchos trozos
pequeños para que todos los miembros de
la familia puedan comer como no tenemos
mucho dinero a veces estamos el pescado
a los niños y nosotros solo comemos la
salsa con una deuda de más de 51
millones de dólares a prestamistas
extranjeros el nuevo presidente tendrá
que seguir las negociaciones con el
fondo monetario internacional un paso
esencial para dar alguna esperanza de
futuro a los 22 millones de sri
lanqueses